This lesson was hard. And it's hard to learn
and it's equally as hard to teach. But there're
some major concepts I want you to take away
from this. So let's try to summarize them into five
main points. Point one. Most traits are complex. And
they exemplify the paradigm of nature and nurture. Point
two, polygenic traits like eye color are controlled by
multiple genes with minimal environmental
influence, whereas multifactorial traits are
controlled by multiple genes with a measurable
environmental impact. Point three, quantitative traits like
weight and height vary continuously over a
range of measurements. Whereas qualitative traits, like Huntington's
disease, are either present or their not.
Point four, monozygotic and dizygotic twins are useful
in studying the heritability of a trait,
when twin correlations are helpful for quantitative traits,
and twin concordances are useful for qualitative
traits. And point five. Genome wide association
studies are useful in determining whether any
candidate alleles influence a particularly complex trait.